machen pornos dumm eine studie hat jetzt
der mitte dass bestimmte bereiche des
gehirns bei bruno kann kleiner sind sind
also pornos schädlich wird
jetzt ging klick zum teil politisch
[Musik]
das ist schon starker tobak da will eine
studie herausgefunden haben dass
bestimmte gehirnregionen bei porno kann
kleiner sind als bei menschen die keine
oder wenig pornos sehen das ist schon
ein bisschen an das ammenmärchen aus dem
achtzehnten und neunzehnten jahrhundert
das onanieren nervenschwäche verursachen
würde
gut man könnte jetzt sagen dass es zu
viele leute mit schwachen nerven gibt
aber es gab und gibt auch nicht den
geringsten wissenschaftlichen beweis
dass es da einen zusammenhang überhaupt
geben könnte
anders scheint das jetzt bei pornografie
und dem gehirn zu sein es gibt wohl
tatsächlich ein zusammenhang
die psychiatrische universitätsklinik an
der berliner charité und das max planck
institut für bildungsforschung haben
jetzt zusammen eine studie
veröffentlicht die beweisen sollen dass
es einen zusammenhang zwischen
gehirnentwicklung und porno konsum gibt
die wissenschaftler haben 64 männer im
alter von 21 bis 45 jahren untersucht
sie wurden zunächst gefragt seit wann
sie pornos gucken und sieben stunden pro
woche danach steckten die forscher die
probanden in einen
magnetresonanztomographen mrt und
erfassten die hirnstruktur und die
gehirnaktivitäten wären sie pornos an
das ergebnis ist verblüffend umso mehr
pornos die männer pro woche gucken umso
weniger graue substanz gab es in ihrem
gehirn also die berühmten grauen zellen
deren anzahl die intelligenz beeinflusst
umso mehr graue zellen umso
intelligenter der mensch und umgekehrt
sind also porno burkert immer zumindest
ein bestimmter bereich des gehirns ist
betroffen dass strato
es ist bei porno gar nicht nur kleiner
es ist auch weniger aktiv die männer die
regelmäßig und oft pornos an hatten beim
anschauen von pornos ein weniger aktives
striatum das schwert um gehört zum
belohnungssystem des gehirns ist erzeugt
ein glücksgefühl wird es weniger
angeregt braucht es mehr anregungen
die forscher gehen von einer art
ausleihen des stroms aus werden ständig
pornos an
umso mehr pornos man sie umso mehr muss
man sehen es müssen also immer mehr
pornos geschaut werden um genauso stark
belohnt zu werden
jetzt könnte es natürlich sein dass das
striatum nicht durch den porno konsum
kleiner geworden ist sondern schon
vorher klein war
das wiederum würde bedeuten dass männer
mit kleinem striatum mehr pornos gucken
die forscher halten das für eher
unwahrscheinlich und wollen jetzt
weitere studien durchführen um ihre
these pornos schlechteres gehirn zu
untermauern
was meint ihr sind pornos schädlich
diskutiert es in den kommentaren
wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt schaut
in europa profit und aktiviert clixoom
unbedingt ansehen auch solltet ihr das
video über die liebes und sex chic link
ist natürlich in der video beschreibung
besonders freue ich mich über eure abos
kost nix und das war hier noch zu sagen
bis dann bleibt dran